des fournitures aux manuels scolaires
tout a été organisé autour de la rentrée
dans cette librairie de montigny le
bretonneux
ici c'est là on range du coup tout ce qu
il était d donc les ce qu'on appelle les
cahiers d'activités
c'est pour le brevet toutes les matières
ou des choses comme ça ici les bleds les
bêches trail légré disent tous les cas
liés aux classeurs copies doubles avec
noël
la rentrée scolaire est un des moments
phares de cette librairie pour le rayon
papeterie
c'est même la période la plus intense de
l'année puisqu'elles représentent près
de 25% de son chiffre d'affaires alors
face aux politiques commerciales très
agressives des grandes surfaces ces
petites enseignes mettent en avant leurs
atouts afin de tirer leur épingle du jeu
ici c'est plus rapide parce qu'on a les
conseils d'une personne alors que dans
le supermarché on trouve où on doit
chercher par nous mêmes le conseil
une attention particulière pour cette
librairie le commerce de fournitures
scolaires représente bien plus qu'une
simple vente ce qui nous différencie de
la grande surface c'est la bonne
connaissance des établissements
scolaires environnants et des listes
scolaires et depuis plusieurs années
nous avons un partenariat avec le
collège giacometti qui nous donnent les
listes scolaires pour chaque niveau
chaque enfant donc nous préparons pour
chaque enfant des cartons les parents
n'ont qu'à venir chercher les
commerçants n'ont en tout cas rien à
redouter de la vente sur internet
elle ne représenterait que 3% du marché
des fournitures scolaires